I'm 71 so far in the playoffs I'd just
like everybody to know that 71 you're 72
I want to see the proof I'm gonna go
with the Colts and an upset here I I'm
gonna go with the Dallas Cowboys I'm
gonna say Chargers win 22:17 Mike Bears
win 24 20 that type of football game I'm
going with the Chiefs I'm thinking the
38:34 type of win but I'm gonna say the
rams are down 23 21 late in the game
drive down kick a field goal win 24 23
I'm gonna say 23 17 hatred I'm going 28
24 New Orleans Saints win seven mo so
far for Chris in the postseason I didn't
believe it I still don't believe it I
think it's been doctored I think it's
all rigged hold on when you said 7 and 1
I thought you were talking about against
the spread Oh 1/4 I think or 101 in 3
last week 1 in 3 laughs yeah yeah I mean
there's no the Bears yeah my bad yeah
not really cool let's get let's get to
this week we've got the Rams at the
Saints the Saints are three and a half
point favorites let's pick it straight
up and let's pick it against the spread
big cat go all right I'm going all
weekend it's the don't overthink it okay
because this is a game when you get two
games left you sit there and you analyze
every little piece and you overthink it
the Saints are in the dome just close
your eyes visualize the Saints the domes
rockin Drew Brees it's his last great
chance to go to a Super Bowl it's the
Saints take the Saints oh I know I mean
these games are so evenly matched this
game is so close I'm gonna go with the
team that I think is more talented in
the Los Angeles Rams I am going to go
with them and and I don't feel totally
comfortable with either one of my picks
cuz I know they're that close but I am
going Rams 27 24 pulling off the upset
in New Orleans I got the Saints 38:31
I'm with big cat on this it just seems
too obvious and you can't overthink it
and if you do you end up shooting
yourself in the foot 3831 Saints win so
I got the Saints covering the three and
a half all right Kansas City hosting the
new
England Patriots this is the tougher one
this one could go either way big cat who
you got don't overthink it again don't
overthink it again if you close your
eyes and you think about the Kansas City
Chiefs versus the New England Patriots
and AFC Championship game the Patriots
are gonna win this game
I mean how many times they have to be
here for this to happen and I like I
said I took the Chargers last week yeah
I always do this I always think the
Steelers are going to beat the Patriots
right I'm done looking stupid yeah just
just take the Patriots and forget it
don't overthink I'm joining you I'm
joining you I'm going Patriots as well
but after my studies and film and me
being Ron Jaworski because I watched the
film I am going 30 to 27
New England Patriots I think hey we can
talk about AFC Championship game on the
road struggles yes but I think this
Patriots team is very good they're made
to play on the road with their run game
and I think their secondary is the best
secondary left in the playoffs the way
they can slow down this Kansas City unit
Mike is it the same I got the same
outcome Patriots 30 27 Mike is it a
problem that Phil and I agree this much
what me and said they please call him
filler tell you guys a secret on the way
out I always pick one of the tie to
remember to pick one of the two
championship games 32 27 because I'm
still scarred from Falcons 30 vikings 27
21 years ago oh my god get over it how
do that with the Vikings were really
good eighteen and one right yeah that
would have been a great Super Bowl game
against the Bronco never think about
that at all
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports